if it was the other way around
that's how it would be for men in a
sense what do you mean in the sense of
this
if men was the one that was
in the position like how how women have
structured it in terms of
it's okay for us to do it but it's not
okay for you to do you think women
corner man and you've already said
multiple times during during this
podcast that you've said that a man is
stronger than a woman so you know you
and your friends going around a single
female is gonna naturally intimidate her
but that's okay because of what she's
wearing how many times have you been hit
before by a man multiple no when you say
multiple how many times because i can't
count i've said i've been in abusive
relationships i've been hit multiple
times yeah but okay but when i say this
i mean the sense of this i think a man
is more has more to be scared of another
man than a woman should be scared of a
man like it's more likely for a man to
to hit another man than for a man to him
no not these days no and i will tell you
that because men are men are more
comfortable going after women because
they know that the woman cannot fend for
themselves exactly so they're not man
enough to go for a man so they're going
to go for a woman because oh wait what i
don't know i see what they're saying
because like we could targets like
that's how they like they see it as
weaker targets but now everyone's just
like like back then there's like mad
fights like pb's to file the time but
now it's kind of like in them
circumstances like we've been like
taught to like find another way around
that so like if we see someone stronger
than us we're not really gonna try to
test them anymore okay okay if you used
to walk down the road naked do you think
someone has the the right to stop you
and ask you if you if you want to but
you're not who's walking around
it doesn't work wait wait wait
wait
i'm going
she was wearing leggings and i could see
every single shirt
i could see everything like you're not
you're not leaving anything for the
imagination like just because i see is
see-through now is see-through but
because it's a leggings now it's okay
but i've seen everything
nah you don't you why are you taking it
there like why does your brain instantly
sexually because i have testosterone and
you have estrogen it's like you saying
why do i have to why do you have so me
walking down and drifting no me walking
down the street in a dress instantly
makes because i look feminine you can
come up to me and make me feel
intimidated because that's literally
what i don't think i don't think you
should feel intimidated i feel that
girls i feel empowered no
i believe girls feel intimidated even
when men don't want to intimidate them
so i'll give it to you like this i'm
just walking down the road chirps and
you you feel intimidated you can't tell
me that when the girl when the when the
woman walks across the road because i'm
walking behind her with a handbag and
she crossed the road quickly that's my
fault
but you know as a man you are bigger you
are
stronger let me finish but it's late at
night and you know by you walking close
you don't know what the [ __ ] she's been
through okay and you might make her feel
uncomfortable by walking close to her so
how do you know that guy is not going to
be the guy that saves her so you've told
me to f off now yeah and you've gone
around the corner wait hold on you've
gone around the corner and an another
guy the best way to stop with one guy
sounds kind of personal bro how about
god
it's like if he was in trouble are you
one of them guys that goes up to girls
in the street late at night and chaps
them speaking to them it depends yeah
depends if she's looking crazy pretty
enough if she's looking uh like
available enough yeah the hand on my
heart i beg you
check yourself before you do that
because you have no idea how
uncomfortable or scared or afraid she
doesn't know you remember you you can be
a lovely i know we've had like disagree
i can see you're a nice guy but she
doesn't know you okay she doesn't know
you and you approaching is intimidating
there's a way you can go about i don't
know obviously how you address a woman
but if you're aware of the time setting
she's alone the surroundings if you're
with multiple people there's a way if
you want to charge her to do it politely
without intimidating that's that's so
unfair i'll tell you why because you
guys don't want to do the chirps in so
okay if you did the chirps in
please be guaranteed for 100 women
wouldn't stop men at two o'clock in the
morning four o'clock in the morning two
it doesn't matter what time it will be
for them so if okay so as a man you
gotta remember i i didn't have a choice
whether or not i was born a man or not
okay so it's not the fact that i'm
stopping you in the middle of the night
because if a girl stopped you in the
middle of the night you would stop and
talk to her it's the fact that i'm a man
so now you're being sexist because
you're not being sick
i tell you why you're being sexist
because you've already decided
what i'm like before you even know me so
it's like okay it's like
you don't see that sexist no i'm saying
that from
you've already said countless times how
men are stronger bigger all of these
things so if it's night time naturally
it's a more vulnerable setting you
you're aware of the power you hold
you're aware of the power you hold
you're making excuses because i'm not
making it you're you're you're you're
you're bigger than him ladies what do
you think about what you're saying i i i
i don't agree with what he's saying like
thank you i do get what you're saying
but it's it's unreasonable because
men are biologically stronger like males
males are not men but males are
biologically stronger and if you're
seeing this and back to the original
statement if it's
you're saying no but i'm not saying i'm
saying that girls don't like a guy
that's shorter than them so the guy
that's it doesn't matter if you're
shorter or not it does because no it
doesn't matter if you're shorter or not
you're biologically stronger than you're
missing my point you're missing my point
i'm saying
i get your point
though i didn't even finish though yeah
yeah because he did just ask me so back
to the original how we started this this
sentence right now or this dialogue you
were talking about guys checking your
friends so in this scenario that because
you're saying on a one-on-one thing
you're what we're originally talking
about is one uh a woman and a guy is
with his friends and then goes up to her
so checking it in that sense you're like
it's two different things but it doesn't
matter if a guy is short or tall a male
is still going to be biologically
stronger than a female so yeah okay
what did you think about what he said
i was going back to what he was saying
about checking the guys you say you
check guys but you guys were also
talking about women checking other women
but do you do the checking in public too
or do you do it one-on-one and in public
or i just i do both because like
because like okay so if i'm with someone
and they start moving like bear bucky
like there's a goat there there's like a
crowd of people and he starts acting up
i'm also gonna get real enough for his
actions so like at the moment i have to
call it out but it's not like i'm not
caught i'm not calling out just because
it's gonna make me seem bad i'm also
calling it out because obviously like i
have sisters and things of that nation i
can't like let that run like i can't be
friends with someone who does that [ __ ]
and then expects like when it happens to
my sister and [ __ ] like i'm just gonna
be like okay then
yeah and to be honest that whole um 2
a.m situation any anything that would
make
a girl feel
really uncomfortable or you know make
her feel unsafe
anything like that would definitely not
fly with me i'll definitely have to
check my mind in that kind of situation
and also like if one of my friends comes
up to me he's like he he saw a girl at 2
a.m
went up to her i'll be like what's wrong
with you because first of all like you
have to understand like a lot is there
now a time limit where you can't allow
you're not allowed to check girls
we associate nighttime activity with
like less protection like people go off
they do drugs they they so why is she
outside then
because maybe
if it's that dangerous why is she
outside because she's trying to go home
no no if it's that dangerous why is she
outside what if she just came home from
work but why is she working where she
has to leave and come out in dangerous
times she has no choice
no i'm not saying that i'm saying this
you know fully well it's not dangerous
because okay i'll tell you why in the
sense of this
[Laughter]
i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why
i tell you why it's not dangerous
because
i'll tell you why
you have you ha okay i me as a man
they will never unders you would never
understand because you're a woman you're
allowed to hit a man and not expect
something to come back it's
not yet exactly it's different you could
hit a man
and he wouldn't hit you back in most
circumstances well if he hit you back
and there's another man around he's
going to get hit
that's just standard yeah but if i'm if
i'm if i'm on the road wait did you just
say if if there are two guides around
and the woman hits the man that the
other man is going to hit the other man
no that's not what i said i said it's
going to check it like the guy is going
to check the the guy that hits the woman
no one's going to check the woman that
hits the man
i have multiple times i've never seen a
man
listen guys there have been um there
have been
social studies done on this that have
been filmed and there have been men and
women both in the street
and
the woman has slapped the man and people
be like oh my god it's crazy
but then the man has just been in
woman's face shouting at her and he's
been checked it's been done multiple
times women are more likely to be seen
as a victim
in those situations do you know what i'm
saying and men are more likely to be
seen as aggressive that's the truth but
i then that goes back to everyone
knowing that men are women or females
females are biologically weaker than
that's your facade it's not a facade
a man's weakness is the facade of his
strength
a woman's strength is the facade of her
weakness if she if if she's acting weak
that's where she gets her strength in
don't act weaker out because you're not
because you said you want equality you
work the same you're strong as us when
it comes to like certain stuff it's like
no we could do it we're girls there's
girl power we could do this but when you
want to and you want to switch off that
little thing it's like oh we're innocent
we don't do nothing oh if you was that
endangered you wouldn't walk at two
o'clock in the morning in london with a
short skirt on and drunk out your head
bopping from side to side london is one
of the safest places in the world right
now what i am saying to you is
you guys are not prepared to go up to
men and chirps them you do not want a
man that's shorter than you so when a
guy that's taller than you and knows
he's your type he's going to come to you